er machte eine 21 jährige junge frau aus
syrien zu seiner sexsklavin in der
oberpfalz presse hat der 22-jährige
kommt der syrischer flüchtlinge nach
deutschland
sein vater ist auch asylbewerber er
schloss die junge frau für seinen sohn
ins land um einen sohn zu zeigen und um
sie nach der geburt des kindes wieder in
die türkei abzuschieben die ehe zwischen
calais und karte wird von den eltern
arrangiert
wenn die frau nicht wie gehofft
funktioniert wird sie mit einem gürtel
ausgepeitscht mit einem kleiderbügel
verprügelt wohnt auf dem berg gefesselt
ihr mann lässt erst von ihr ab wenn sie
ihren garten die füße küsst nach der
geburt ihres sohnes im februar 2009 10
soll sie wieder aus dem land geschafft
werden
sie rettet sich in ein türkisches
flüchtlingscamp drei monate später kommt
sie wieder nach deutschland und mit
ihrem sohn in einem frauenhaus zu leben
zu ihrer familie nach syrien können sie
nicht wieder zurück sie habe schande
über die familie gebracht jemand après
ski mit entwürdigenden videos auf denen
es zu sehen wie sie zum oral und
analverkehr gezwungen wird jetzt beim
heutigen prozess wird ein urteil
erwartet
bild reporter jörg völkerling ist bei
gericht bei diesem fall ja heute soll
ein urteil fallen
in welchem strafmaß wird gerechnet der
vater ist wegen menschenraubs angeklagt
er soll seinen lebensunterhalt
regelrechter mit bestritten haben
landsleute hier nach deutschland zu
bringen und auch pässe seiner
neunköpfigen familie dafür verliehen
haben dafür droht ein höchstmaß an
strafe von zehn jahren
dem sohn werden unter anderem dreifache
vergewaltigung körperverletzung und
andere straftaten vorgeworfen
dafür könnten ihm bis zu 15 jahre haft
drohen und der staatsanwalt hat keinen
hehl daraus gemacht dass er hier
sicherlich auch bis an die obergrenze
gehen könnte
zeigten sich dein vater und sohn jetzt
reumütig in diesem prozess das ist das
eigentlich schockierende sie haben
keinerlei reue gezeigt sie haben nichts
gestanden von dem was ihm zur last
gelegt wurde
sie haben sich raus geredet sie haben
sogar während der aussage von kdb tieren
gericht haben sie offenbar bedrohende
gesten in ihre richtung gemacht hat sich
beim gericht beschwert der richter
musste dann eindringlich auf die
angeklagten einreden sie haben versucht
konspirativen mit familienmitgliedern
kontakt aufzunehmen justizbeamten
beobachtet wieder ein mobiltelefon hin
und her ging also das ganze gegenteil
von reue haben sie hier vor gericht
gezeigt wie geht es der mittlerweile dem
opfer und ihren kennt ja katar war ja
drei monate von ihrem kind getrennt sie
wurde unter dem vor unter dem vorwand
dass man ihre aufenthalts verlängerung
griechenland verlängern müsse dorthin
gelockt und dann dort in ein türkisches
flüchtlingscamp sozusagen interniert
ihre familie meldete sie als vermisst
sie kam dann in deutschland in einem
frauenhaus unter und versteckt sich dort
bis heute
sie hatten zwischen deutsch gelernt ihre
anwältin hat uns gesagt sie hat immer
noch angst vor den beiden strafe ist ja
eigentlich nicht mehr so wichtig sie
wollte in erster linie darauf aufmerksam
machen was eigentlich mit frauen aus dem
arabischen burgeis geschieht und wer ein
gespräch mit ihrem cousin hat qatar
selber mal dieses martyrium angedeutet
hat gesagt das was sie da an gewalt
erfahren hat geht weit über das hinaus
was im arabischen kulturkreis vielleicht
für normale achtet wird im umgang mit
frauen